i know you said you're not really
nervous about
like social media and people and what
they think but do you ever get nervous
about your career yeah uh well but this
is the thing man
if i talk about me it's still me
like it's me
this is my experience his i'll give you
an example of what he did that i i don't
think i would ever have the strength the
fortitude to do you know during the
the metoo movement
when that first began you know terry is
the poster boy for
male metoo movement
and if i went to a part and i think
you're absolutely right and i'm with you
i was with you but i thought
how the [ __ ] do you even you know
i don't know if you know the story
jackie do you know the story of he went
to a party
the agent grabbed him
inappropriately but if that happened to
me i would hate it as much as you
[ __ ] hated it you know and i think
this is inappropriate and it's wrong
i don't think i would ever have whatever
it takes to be public about it not only
be public about it but just hammer it
and hammer it and hammer it until there
is a result
and
to that end
is to to what jackie was just speaking
about you know it's a powerful agency
yeah and you were asking for this person
to be canceled that's right because just
like every ma every uh man that was
inappropriately abusing their power
violating women was cancelled and you
felt like just because you're a man
this guy is going to get away with it
and you you sought through right to the
end
that's
i i could never have done that and i
don't know what that takes to do that
well you know and this is
this and the only reason i did
is remember what fuels addiction what
fuels the rage is the helplessness
and i said i'm not helpless
i'm not helpless
this is what i can do
and by doing that
i gain my power
like by just
were you not afraid that you would lose
you gain your personal power but were
you not afraid that you would lose your
um opportunities oh yeah oh no i told my
after i tweeted out what happened i came
home and i said hey honey
hollywood's over
i said we're out
and she was like what are you talking
about i said i told she was like about
bennett you told she was like yep cuz
she was right there she saw the whole
thing right she said you said something
i said no i did more than say something
i wrote it and put it out it's going
viral as we speak she's like what
and she said you know what
she said terry
we had to start over after football
we'll start over after this i said okay
are we good she said we're good we fist
bumped because this is another thing i
didn't do this alone
i she was right there with me the whole
time and she was terry you need to do
this because
this is another way but she wasn't you
just you know what i mean is
there's never there's no women in my
family that have been
inappropriately
uh abused abused and so she was like you
know what terry
this stuff happened to me
this is what we're going gonna do and i
was like yup and i was just listening to
her listening and it was so wild because
as the women were coming forward
i was just following their lead i was
actually just in a my whole thing to
come forward was to support the women
who did that because i didn't even name
adam bennett at first i didn't even put
his name out there
but all these dude everybody the whole
internet was like they're calling them
[ __ ] and hoes and yeah that's what
you got to do to get in hollywood yeah
they liked it but the thing is no one
gets paid to tell
you get paid for silence
when you as soon as you tell you ain't
getting no money
i didn't get no money
you know what i mean like you don't as
soon as you speak it it's a wrap your
your check is over anybody ever got a
check you were quiet
okay right and so everyone felt like all
this they're trying to get some big
payday i'm like oh no no
because that happened to me and i'm
sitting there the whole time like that
happened to me
yeah then i you know i had the
conversation with my castmates on
brooklyn 99 before i even went public
they were like what i was like dude
they're crazy and they were like oh
that's so crazy
then i went i need to tell this stuff so
when what was the straw that broke the
camel's back because i'm sure you were
thinking about it for a while while it
was going on how long how long from the
time it went on to the time you went
public oh it was it was a year
oh it was a year but answer her question
what was the straw that broke the camera
oh the straw was was the straw was again
went i when the as soon as everyone did
was the new york times had all this this
article about all this stuff that
weinstein was doing
and and then when i just went online and
i saw all these people who were doing
who were just dogging these women out
and i said this is not true
and i was sitting on set and i just
started tweeting
i mean i literally let i wrote the whole
thing out
and i remember it all was in like a
a whole little system and then i just
pressed go like i let all the tweets out
at once and i felt and i went back to
work
and then i saw it was so funny people
were holding the lights and stuff and
people were looking at me like oh like
like you saw it popping up on people's
screens yeah well people were like
as i was continuing the day
you could feel the energy it was like oh
my god oh my god then my phone was
buzzing and my publicist was calling i
had no listen no my wife didn't know
nobody knew i just but it was this is
how you know it's something
that triggered like it was something
that i needed to do
that was was
it had to change like i knew that was
the only thing i could do
and i did it
and it felt like wow i felt like a
thousand pounds off my back now you mind
you i went to the agency the next day
like
it wasn't like i didn't go people like i
didn't bring it up to the agency why
didn't you tell uh dude i told every he
i told our emanuel adam bennett my own
agent brad slater i told my manager i
told everybody and i was like what are
you gonna do oh we gonna take this very
seriously oh this is crazy then it calls
me i'm so sorry i was drunk i'm sorry
i'm like yeah man but but hey i'm the
client
you're like dude you can't do that to
the clients what is gonna happen well
we're gonna we're gonna do it and
nothing happened
zero
zero
and then a year then finally i get a
call from aria emanuel who's like uh i
wanna sit down and meet with you at the
four seasons beverly hills i was like oh
so like he was like i'm going to do you
the benefit of actually meeting with you
and i was like wow
and then when i met with him i said hey
man you know you work for me he laughed
he said oh yeah okay uh
okay what we're gonna do what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna take his title
and we're gonna give him three months
suspension i said hey man
you can't touch the clients and go back
to work
period
that's that's not enough for me he said
that's not enough
i said dude
what he did i was like yo man i'm the i
i'm the client i pay you i paid you
millions of dollars if i said if i went
to vines and the guy bagging my
groceries grabbed my balls
hey man he's fired
you don't get
i don't now you could get continue to
shop at vans thank you very much and the
whole thing i'm like no
but he can make an excuse i grabbed the
wrong bag
you want paper or flesh
dude i said that's not enough for me
and they were like because they thought
i wanted millions of dollars that was
the big thing like okay he's waiting for
a big paid i said no i said what i want
is he cannot be an agent
you you you goofed it up you had your
shot
you goofed it up
go go do something else wow but you
can't be an agent anymore
who's gonna i mean what you gonna send
your you gonna send your daughter to go
work with this guy you're gonna send
your son to go work with him huh nah
my son's in the business right now i
know you see what i'm saying yeah and
he's doing his thing but i know there's
a bunch of adam venice out there
okay and i'm like hey
no and watch yourself look out man and i
said this guy blew it he had a shot
you're ahead of the movie department
bruh you you should know more than
everybody in the whole building
that you can't put your hands on the
clients
you're gone and they were like no sorry
they said we agreed to disagree and you
know what i brought up i brought up mel
gibson
ari emanuel wrote a letter on the
huffington post saying that mel gibson
should be banned from hollywood for
anti-semitic remarks right and i said
hey man anti-semitic remarks as
reprehensible as they are they're not
even illegal
i said dude
so you saying
mel gibson should be out but your boy
who did a crime
literally punishable
by law
he should be fine
i said man read your own [ __ ] man read
your own letter he was i kept
sorry i agree to disagree i was like i
know how you playing it
so we gonna go all the way and see that
was another thing because every one of
those little indiscretions
you know they call a micro that was a
macro aggression
you know he was like [ __ ] you i was like
whoa
you're gonna really i'm coming to meet
with you and you literally end with [ __ ]
you like hey i was like all right
see you never he went i kept going i was
like yo man he gave me no choice
they gave me no other recourse i was
like all right we got to go all the way
there i spent 500 000
of my own money howie
my own money and i said you know what
i'll spend a million to win a dollar
and i said i'll probably never work
again
but i know i'm doing the right thing
like my wife was like we're with you she
said i'm with you wow and
and
what happened
he ended up
retiring is what happened because what
happened was you know you don't rob the
biggest bank in l.a you've been robbing
little banks all the way till you get to
terry crews okay so what happened were
other people who came forward and they
were like yeah he did this to me and
we'll join your case privately
and the whole thing and then they they
said no mouse because it would start it
was going to get
real ugly
and i was like how far you want to take
it and they were like okay we're done
so he's going to retire we're going to
give you all your fees back
that you spent on your lawyer and we'll
be done
i was like thank you
that's what i wanted in the first place
that's all i wanted wow and that's
heroic it's but but this thing man
heroes it's always an accidental hero do
you think they learn their lesson no do
you no right i mean it's not them it's
humanity oh yeah i know but i mean the
agency it sounds like when more people
started coming and when they saw that it
was going to be a loss for them then
okay we'll take the l and move on it
wasn't because there was so much remorse
oh it was it was dirt i mean it was they
had private investigators following me
they had fake stories they were making
up going right to the press i mean come
on it was i was getting warned they were
like well we
we have
pictures and things with you with
prostitutes and uh and monte carlo and
the whole thing and we're about to go
public and all day i was like go ahead
that's my wife that's a picture of me
and my wife you know that right i said
you know what you just called her
hey man i'm sorry bro
but this is the thing about coming
forward and being transparent is that my
dirt anything i had ever done was
already out
like i they didn't have anything to be
like ah we got you i was like no man
i've been to therapy almost six seven
years now so and i've already been
forward about anything that you could
try to twist on me so and me and my wife
worked it out so
now
because that's where the honesty
came for me and protected you sleep well
don't you i sleep so freaking good
[Music]
you